it's taking forever to get to mars
there's really no doubt about it after
founding nasa
we were able to get to the moon in less
than 11 years
today it's been 50 years since we've
even been to the moon
so why in the world is it taking so long
to get to mars
well starting off even if we put
technological concerns to the side
we are faced with a plethora of
logistical concerns
first of all getting to the moon only
takes 3 days
getting to mars takes between 6 and 9
months
thus the amount of food supplies and
rocket fuel will need
is exponents ahead of the moon and
whenever you put something
extra into the rocket like let's say a
banana
you'll be adding volume to the rocket as
well as mass
which means you need more rocket fuel
and to make things even worse
the extra rocker fuel you just added is
also adding volume
and mass to the rocket so now you need
even more rocket fuel
to carry the rocket fuel that's supposed
to be used to carry the banana
as you can see each extra bit of mass
requires
exponentially more rocket fuel and when
you're looking at a six
to nine month voyage it's pretty clear
why this would turn into a big issue
very quickly
the straightforward solution to this
conundrum is
to simply send the required supplies in
multiple supply runs to mars
before embarking on a crude mission but
this
is extremely expensive we are sending
multi-billion dollar space shuttles
on one-way trips to mars just to provide
six months worth of supplies so the
first hurdle would be to develop
fully reusable rockets but we have yet
to crack the code on even this
something else to consider is the health
and mental state
of a crew traveling in a can for more
than six
months in deep space simply staying in
the iss
for six to 12 months brings up a lot of
health concerns regarding weightlessness
muscle mass and bone density plummet
without the help of gravity
and even when you reach mars you'll have
a similar issue
as martian gravity is 62 percent less
than the gravitational force on earth
moreover
you still have the trip back as well
nasa estimates
that due to the different orbital
periods of the earth and mars
even if you only stay at mars for a mere
3 months
the trip there and back would take 18
months
thus putting the total duration of the
trip at 21 months
considering this you'll also need to
send plenty of exercise equipment within
the spacecraft itself nasa estimates
that
after accounting for all of the food
water
equipment and everything else to get a
crew of six to mars
and back we would need three million
pounds of supplies to put that in
perspective the space shuttle was
only capable of carrying 50 000 pounds
that's an astounding amount but just a
fraction of 3 million
we would need 60 space shutter ones to
mars just to support
one crude mars mission even if we were
doing a space shuttle launch
every month it would take 5 years to
make this happen
spacex's new starship rocket makes this
significantly easier
as it is expected to be able to carry
100 metric tons of space
or 220 000 pounds but
even with starship we would need 10 to
15 supply runs
just for one crude mission evidently
the logistics of completing a mars
mission is a nightmare
but it's not just the logistics that
have been holding us back
in many cases it's the technology itself
sure we may have already had the
technology
to send people to mars decades ago but
what about actually landing them on mars
safely
the atmosphere of mars is very thin
so we can't use the atmosphere as an
effective braking system
if you've ever seen a mars rover landing
you'll know
that it's no easy task we have to use
parachutes
airbags and sky cranes and even with
all of that the landing is not very
pleasant
to say the least plus that's just a few
thousand pound rover
imagine trying to land a several hundred
thousand pound rocket ship
on mars sure we may be able to create
some sort of small mars landing system
for the crew but what about all the
supply runs
those have to reach the martian surface
safely as well
even if you develop a rocket ship that
has no trouble
dealing with the martian atmosphere we
have to keep in mind
that there is no landing infrastructure
available on the martian surface
no runways no landing pads no oceans to
splash down in
thus the rocket would have to be capable
of landing
on a variable rocky terrain but
more importantly how would we even take
off from mars
after the martian trip is over and i'm
not talking about the logistics
of getting fuel rocket launches are no
simple task
thousands of engineers mechanics and
scientists
monitor each and every step of the
rocket launch
from ensuring that there is not even the
slightest bit of damage on the vehicle
to ensuring that each and every system
is working correctly during launch
the thing is when you are launching from
mars you can't get any help
during the launch itself this is because
it takes
3 to 22 minutes for information to
travel
one way between mars and the earth and
that's
at the speed of light so even the best
case scenario
would require 6 minutes for back and
forth conversation
and as we all know it just takes seconds
for something to go horribly wrong and
we on earth
wouldn't even know until a minimum of
three minutes
after it happens the solution to this
issue would be to either have a super
reliable rocket
requiring no maintenance or a
communication infrastructure that's
faster than the speed of light this
space shuttle required
thousands of hours of work between
launches and
we currently think that it's impossible
to travel faster than the speed of light
thus the technological limitations of
rocket reusability
and communication have been large bottle
caps over the past few decades
but really none of this is actually the
problem
yes getting to mars is extremely hard
logistically psychologically
technologically
and basically every other realm however
none of those are the real reason we
have yet to get to mars
the number one reason mars has yet to
happen
is politics nasa is a government agency
and is run and funded by the government
including congress
and the white house and politicians are
only going to be pushing goals
that have large public support yeah
most people think that going to mars
would be cool
but most of them would also rather have
better health care
less taxes or more welfare going to mars
is not the number one political focus of
the public
or politicians and nasa's funding
as well as their goals have been shaped
with this in mind
this isn't a bad thing it's no doubt
that there are many concerns
on earth that are much more significant
to the average person
than going to mars and in many cases
it makes more sense to focus on problems
on earth
but unfortunately a side effect of this
approach
was the stifling of nasa's mars vision
in the early 1970s nasa actually planned
to go to mars in the 1980s
of course this never happened but this
wasn't because of technological or
logistical limitations
if spacex a company that till very
recently
was barely staying afloat using
relatively small cargo mission checks
from nasa the air force and other
entities
if they are even in the realm of
possibly reaching mars within the next
decade
it is no question whether or not nasa
who has a budget that's tens of times
greater than that of
spacex even with all the budget cuts
and over double the employees could have
gotten people
to mars the answer is yes
with their 20 plus billion annual budget
and the smartest rocket engineers in the
world
they could have overcome all the
technical challenges in getting to mars
within the past few decades and they
wanted to do it
as well but political influence made
this
impossible to achieve for instance
during the nixon administration
nasa's budget crashed from four percent
of the federal budget
to less than one percent this led to
apollo 18
19 and 20 being abandoned aside from
this
president nixon also approved what would
eventually become nasa's space shuttle
program
this shifted nasa's focus away from the
moon and
mars and onto low earth orbit and
this focus on low earth orbit would
continue till 2004
when george bush announced that nasa
would focus on getting people to the
moon
and eventually mars this led to the
creation
of the constellation program but this
would
instantly be fully cancelled by barack
obama
president obama ditched the moon plan
and said
let's just go to mars and this was
making some decent progress
until president trump changed it back to
moon and then mars
in 2017 the constant changing of what
nasa was supposed to accomplish
has led to very little progress in any
realm
this isn't necessarily the president's
faults either
they have to manage so many different
programs and sacrifices
must be made here and there and
unfortunately
one of those sacrifices was going to
mars
anyways looking forward elon musk is
well aware of this
and this is the main reason he adamantly
refuses
to take spacex public until after
reaching mars
and hopefully the laser focus they enjoy
by not going public will be just what we
need to reach mars
by 2030. do you guys believe that we'll
finally make it to mars this decade
drop a like if you guys think so and of
course consider subscribing to see more
questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari
and i'll see you guys on the next one
you